welcome to the recruitment roller
coaster podcast my name
is hisham azuz today i'm joined by
andy morrell who is the ceo at oscar
who are an award-winning recruitment
agency that andy joined in 2007.
they deliver talent across technology
digital energy and construction
they have a global footprint as a
business with
offices in manchester london austin and
houston
there's circa 80 people who currently
work for the brand
and are currently sitting at 28 million
turnover as a
business andy thank you for joining them
good morning how are you
i'm good uh how's it been how's life
been over the last couple of months andy
talk to us
um do you know what i think on a
relative basis
um pretty good um really thankful
on a personal level i think for having
outdoor space family around me
you know to help with uh with mental
health and things like that and
business-wise it's been challenging but
we've come through it pretty well and um
fingers crossed i think we're going to
come out of it stronger than we went
into it with so um
happy but um it's been a real graft
grasp
and our guys have put in monumental
efforts
yeah so andy i've been looking forward
to this
oscar is a brand that i associate with
one of the
sort of leading recruitment businesses
up north hopefully
yeah so so i'm sure there's lots of
people interested
to know more about the oscar story and
the andes andy's story
so we're gonna we're gonna focus today
on you joining oscar and that sort of 13
year or so only but just for context so
how
from what i saw online you've been
working in recruitment before nearly
like 20 years basically
um three months from yesterday
i'll be 20 years exactly wow okay so 20
years
october 23rd 2000 okay and then for like
pretty much 13 and a bit of those that
you've been oscar
yes that's right yeah okay so we're
gonna focus on
the oscar journey so before that from
what i saw you was a contract
um it manager for for a business
and you joined oscar in 2007.
why didn't we why don't we start i know
we said before this that
things a lot of things change at oscar
when you moved from disbury to
to manchester but when you joined the
business
what what did it look like just for
context
um so i was um kind of parachuted in by
the owners of the business
um a bit of a turnaround sort of change
project really
um the company has been going since 2001
um
started i mean not a lot of people in
recruitment remember
everyone remembers 2017 2009 right the
financial crash
and things were difficult in the early
2000s as well in tech
and first.com bubbler burst uh post y2k
there was
an awful lot of engineers in the market
and not jobs um
and the businesses sort of started it in
that fire really
um and i think because it started as a
tech recruitment business
um by guys who've worked together before
um
and over the course of sort of those six
years or so from then
because it was a difficult time in tech
i think we branched out and
started to do a little bit of everything
so what i walked into was a small
business you know sort of single
single uh figures of staff but there was
like there's like
there's two junior guys doing tech
there's two guys doing
uh in uh rec direct there's two guys
doing oil and gas there's two guys doing
rail
it was just kind of like a bit all over
the place um and they were without a
leader
and because the previous directors had a
bit of a fallout
then so i went in as an md just to kind
of
put in processes um that were linked up
between all these disparate parts of the
business
um they weren't really working on a
unified database
and seemed to me at the time let the the
lead
consultants change the commission
structure every month to see what was
going on with their business
um it was there were some good people
there
um and it had potential but it was a
little bit of a
i don't know um like a boy's club in a
way do you know today
it didn't feel like a business and i
think um there was i said
there were some really nice people and
there's some people with potential that
we built around and two of them
eventually made directors
amazing um but it was starting from you
know we were in a spitting sawdust
office above a
a charity shop and a bookies in the pub
and it was it was that kind of
it was that kind of environment really
um and i think that
as with a lot of recruitment businesses
the existing
uh population there had kind of been
bred to by the person that ran it
whoever comes down after this isn't
going to be as nice as me and they'll be
horrible to you and blah blah blah
so i kind of i walked into a bit of a uh
bit of a wall of hate to be honest with
you
so 27 was interesting yes so you joined
there when you was 27
yeah okay yeah and obviously before then
you had
lead teams like manage teams as well
yeah i'd only i've worked in one
business started as a trainee
um in 2000 late 2000 it contracts so
very salesy
very old school like standard hours were
half eight to half seven
that kind of that kind of environment
which i'm really glad i did
um because you kind of i think again
from
you forged strong relationships and i
think strong ethics from that
um and i was i was i would gone through
from being trained to running a division
and i i i was quite successful in
training and managing people that's
where i really found my
umph i was i was a good recruiter but i
was never the best
um then i was overly salesy but i loved
working with people from
it's that old typical background of
having led sports teams and all that
kind of stuff of being younger
and and taking that and then maybe
learning to be not so one-dimensional
and
the you know as the year's path and so
i'd led teams and i got to the stage
where
i was running a contract division i
didn't think i was ever going to get
directorship of that business or
ownership of it i
i was kind of considering to stop on
your own what did you do and then this
opportunity came to kind of
to go into something where the there's a
very shaky platform there's a platform
there
um but it's a challenge build it and see
what you can do with it and yeah
so yeah so i i took that the opportunity
up and then
it was very different because everybody
who'd worked under me before as a
manager
had been trained by me since day one so
they're totally different
they've seen me build they bought into
me they bought into what i could develop
other people into
and so you come into a culture you
become indoctrinated by it right
i could go in and indoctrinate them into
what i wanted
the business to do what i thought it
could do rather than me sort of go
native and just going to be there be
their friends because
that way you don't actually affect
change yeah and
so it was a it was a it was an
interesting start
um because we kind of i heard about it
on i think it was like the thursday and
then i went into tuesday morning we went
in
we interviewed me and the owners sort of
interviewed all the staff how'd you feel
about this
where are you going with it blah blah
blah they disappeared and left me to it
and i was like
actually yeah i'm in the business what
do i do now i obviously didn't know what
to do i remember walking to the
boardroom
and there's like a little corner away
from the window in the door you couldn't
see i just sat there for about 10
minutes i was like
right head together what did you do now
and then it was just like
you trust your instincts and your
processes really go from there okay
so we're gonna attempt to sort of break
down this this journey that you've been
on
right so why don't we try and think
about the early days the first three to
five years
which i'm sure a lot went on but i know
when you said
obviously so when you moved to
manchester from didsbury which is i'm
assuming where this
original office was when you joined um
why did things start to change from
there um
i think i went in in quarter two of
um 2007. again bearing in mind
it's just the start of the financial
crisis so amazing timing again
um but um i think for me
i wasn't going to go somewhere and just
um
just tread water and it was important
that we invested in things properly
and we made it a viable business that
could grow um
consistently and sustainably and i think
you have to show investment in people i
mean actually
those of you if you know fidget spree
it's a lovely place in south manchester
i lived in ditsbury
so the office was like two minutes drive
yeah from matt from michigan
i've been to disney business park
because i've been to uh moribund finney
james
yeah yeah so it was just between we were
just in the village from there so
that's what wasn't as swanky as those
guys um but um
so it was my i've never worked in
manchester before actually where i
worked previously was out in cheshire
but my i started to try and recruit for
the business and i was realizing that
people from the city center or the
satellite towns
north east and west of uh manchester
would they'd be loath to go to disbury
over the city center right yeah
the m60 is a pig um and various other
reasons so
figuring right if we go to the city
center i'll be able to attract people
from
uh not only sort of south manchester
stockport disbury hail round there
but also wigan and bolton and oldham and
people relocating as well potentially
yeah and it was just at the time when i
think there was a really
bit of an explosion of growth of uh city
centre living
because in the in the past in manchester
not many people actually lived in the
city centre
you know in the late 90s after a certain
time
of the weekend it was a ghost town
everybody came in from the suburbs but
there was this explosion the urban
splashed off everybody was building
flats
and i figured that the young sort of
go-getters which traditionally we build
recruitment
uh businesses around when we do it
organically you're post-university guys
and obviously manchester's the biggest
university city in the uk
a lot of them want that you know that
kind of that that new york loft
lifestyle where you walk to work you
grab a starbucks you go to the gym
and then after work if you want there's
a bar on the corner or a restaurant or
what have you
and i figured that this was cool but for
me
i thought the potential in growing it
into something um
interesting would be from the city
center so
we we took a massive punt we took out a
10-year lease on a
an office or four thousand square feet
wow
um and went from there i mean we could
only do that because
to be fair the first sort of six months
or so after i've gone into the guys
responded quite well
quite well in the main and we could see
straight away we
we could see a path forwards out of the
it and the oil and gas um
areas of the business and the rest of it
we just got rid off okay
interesting so what what was your vision
for this business for the first
when you got to manchester for the first
three to five years what was you
thinking was you just
just thinking growth was you thinking i
need to get
some core processes in place to enable
us to scale
i'm assuming that from it seems like
from the get-go
this is a business that you're looking
at scaling so like what was what was the
vision for the business for the first
sort of three to five years once you got
to manchester
um i think long-term vision and the type
of vision that we deliver now
to our businesses we didn't have um and
you know admittedly so i don't think
i'd ever been exposed to a vision that
the business i worked for
had been a relatively sort of small to
medium-sized business
and you were never given that by the
owners it was
you work hard you make money and you can
kind of organically grow up through the
business well
where that goes we don't know um and
i'll be honest with you
it was just well we just keep doing that
and see where it takes us
um and we you know to be honest with you
even until
it was probably only five years ago that
we really had a proper structured vision
in the business
that we were able to deliver out to the
people it worked for us to buy into
it back then it was it was you brought
into your own store and
your own needs at once and really if the
business gave you the platform to do
that that was great
you didn't think about um people buying
into the larger picture of the
organization or what's that we didn't
i'm sure the business out there that did
um but not really having any
guidance so interesting you you just
followed what you i suppose what you
knew but wanted to do it better
yeah so why don't we there nandy i think
why don't we break this down where we
talk about
the business up until that point where
you made the time to think about vision
values etc which i'm sure went into this
because i'm sure because i keep hearing
this andy i'll be honest that
it's really common that recruitment
business that end up scaling they get to
this point where like well actually we
need to think of
what we need to be aligned with and that
really impacts culture and scalability
etc so
i guess was the focus more on then right
we need to get some good people through
the door
we need some good processes what what
did you focus on implementing that you
think
helped you get because where was you as
a business before
that the last five year five years ago
when you thought about the vision these
things where was the business at that
point
so we we've we've actually had it our
growth hasn't been linear you know we've
we've had a lot we have the ideal lotus
monster like
like a lot of recruiters do it with the
desk right we've had that as a business
based on a number of different things so
so to break down into areas if you like
yeah um so from 2008 we moved to
manchester
um for the first couple of years um
we're doing at this point we're doing
tech in the uk
and we're doing oil and gas globally
from manchester
because it's a global market mainly
permanent stuff super high fees
i mean when i walked in there we you
know we're dealing with some clients at
40 percent
on on on you know 150k salaries right
so you're able to do some some big deals
but um
it wasn't there was no sustainability or
consistency to it and
um we identified um
two guys to build what one guy will
build tech around you one guy will build
oil and gas around you
and um 2008 2010 2011
uk economy wasn't great right uh well
the world economy wasn't great but the
oil price was still pretty good
so the oil and gas guys are still having
a great time of it and the tech team
are growing slowly but surely and then
i supposed to jump a little bit with
talk aries he flipped that on its head
to 2014 2015
when the oil price crashes but the
economy's doing kind of okay in the uk
so the tech guys keep them up so
um often often i suppose it's been a
spread of risk but there's also a
counterbalance with one part of the
business doing
the other but in those early years it
was we were just trying to
be honest with you i was trying to first
replicate what i've done successfully
in my previous business which was why i
was asked to do this job in the first
place
to grow to scale to build out vertical
markets
uh with consistent processes to train i
was
in my previous business i'd written sort
of the training suite that all the
managers used
i was quite passionate about it because
that was going to be my question andy
when you say that what what did you what
were the things that you focused on
implementing that you think
could give it the platform to be
successful
it was at the time it was all organic
growth it's picking up graduates and
taking them from there
one because we wouldn't have attracted
anybody decent was experienced well
i thought that was the odd couple but
for the main part no we didn't have a
brand we weren't really well known
um and it was it was putting them
through
i suppose essentially the training that
i'd set up for my previous business
and just trying to replicate that and
replicate that there are obviously
nuances of the oil and gas industry
um which we which i found very difficult
myself individually
to come to terms with because that
wasn't something that i knew about when
i first
joined the business did you deliver this
i delivered all the sales training and
all the and the candidate acquisition
and through that process training and we
started
as the company grew we started then to
try and pad that out i mean we've had a
training function
for the last about five or six years
we've had
a training manager um actually looking
for a new l d manager now if anybody's
interested
so we but again that came organically
out of somebody who was who
became subject matter expert in a
certain part of recruitment life cycle
wasn't really a sales person but was was
a real good asset to the business
and we i suppose we built a function out
of this chat
uh but we started to decentralize
training a little bit
and have other people bring in parts to
it as as the recruitment process changes
and as it evolves and bringing in people
to do
what they're best at but for me the most
important thing was being super granular
with it
and really really detail orientated i
i think one of the reasons i became
quite good at recruitment in the first
place again i don't think i'm a great
salesperson but
i really hate [ __ ] losing first of
all i can't stand losing i've been that
way through sporting background
and but i found a way to so if you like
that i think you'll find a way to win
and i found a process that worked really
really well and and matt south was who's
our
rmd for the uk uh he's the person that
we built
the it piece around and he was similar
really
really good guy really solid really
really process driven
and for me i think if you can put those
processes in place
but allow and then hire people that are
bright and intelligent and allow them to
use their creative spark within it
so they're not inhibited by it you can
build a model that then is scalable
i mean we've all worked with people that
are super talented really you know
uh could charm the snakes down from the
trees sort of thing but um
those people i think it's really really
difficult to scale that
so don't think you can build a business
that grows on that and
so for me it was it was about finding
consistency
i've always been a big advocate of
finding out what good work uh good looks
like
and that made them that might be
different from territory or from
from vertical market or from industry or
from brand and actually from individual
skill set in a way as well
but then trying to replicate that and
that's a good way of growth you know
i was told in my early days of
recruitment find out who the top builder
is go and sit with them buy them lunch
take them for a pint
and just just just bend their ear you
know
in theory if you can do exactly what
they're doing why can't you get the same
results and i don't think it's
necessarily
as straightforward as that because i
think personality is a big big thing
but if you do it within that framework i
think you've got every chance of success
that's really interesting so so did a
lot of your core focus end up on
being the process around training
development because getting in grads and
non-experienced people in
and then obviously yeah refining that
getting great at that
and then and what other what other sort
of processes or
even potentially tools did you start to
implement that
helps you get more of the good out of
people and help
build this solid platform that you felt
could give you the best chance of
scaling
i think for me a lot of it
is it if you talk about
being able to maximize somebody's
potential up when somebody comes to you
and joins you straight out of uni or
from a sales job
all they are is this bag of potential
recruitment wise they've not done it
before right
so it's it's it's finding that that
mixture of different things that will
make them maximize that potential
now often one of the things i learned
the hard way actually
um is it's not actually making them the
best recruiter they can be necessarily
and i've got a little a little equation
that i use so so forgive me risk is very
rudimentary but
so i i used to manage people i used to
be so evangelical back in
my late latter days at senator my early
days at oscar i wanted to get everybody
to do better than male 1 than to be a
hundred percent because
i felt when i went there anything that
went out the door of oscar had my name
on it
yeah um and and i i'm a bit of a
perfectionist right but what i realized
was that when you manage people that
hard and you mean the right things right
you genuinely you do it for them but you
imagine that hard
and you get so upset about little things
they don't do right
what happens is you you i i say i could
make you a 10 out of 10 recruiter right
but for the things i'd have to do and
you'd have to do to get to that stage
you'll want to do the job and you're
driving your desire and and
and your motivation will probably drip
to a two or three right see output ten
times two or ten times three
say twenty or thirty right that's that
[ __ ] out what you get from somebody
yeah whereas let's say
actually what we wanna do is get maximum
output it's not about it's not about
being right it's about winning it's not
about
making them technically the best
recruiters in the world it's about
putting them in a situation where they
do the best job
so if i get to a stage where you're my
trainee history and i say i can get you
i can get you you'll do the rest you see
this
seven seven or eight out of ten without
all the [ __ ] that we've got to go
through to get you 10 out of 10
i guarantee that your wants for the job
and your motivation will still remain at
an 809 or a 10
right yeah so what's 10 times 7
70 that's a lot more than 30 right
so i think for me it
to to answer the ques the original
question what else did you put in place
it's not just about technical training
it's about creating the environment that
they'd be thriving but also want to work
in and stay in
for longevity purposes and it took me a
long time to get that right
long long time um but it's it's building
it's building role models it's building
pillars it's building people they want
to be and want to work for
they've got to want to work with you and
for you as well
and you've got to be able to give them a
clear route to money it's got to be
super super transparent about how they
get to the next stage in their career
how they earn x amount of pounds to to
pay off their student debt to buy the
first house to go on a swanky holiday
to whatever it is they want to do i
think those things are really important
and it's also about giving them all the
tools
so they don't feel because we all have
those [ __ ] days or weeks in recruitment
right
the last thing i ever want is somebody
who works oscar and those days ago
well if i was up the road and i had this
super sexy crm or
or linkedin recruiter license that i
don't have here then i'd do better so we
give them what they need and if you come
back if you combine those things for me
then i think you've got the best chance
of success yeah and that's the journey
you've been on it seems like then to
build all this together so where was the
business five years ago then before you
in like what what prompted the focus on
vision and like did you have any values
at that point what like because it seems
like
yeah you had to go through that learning
process but where was yours a business
five years ago
it's that whole thing isn't it you know
it takes a decade to become an overnight
success right and i think
i don't think there was a moment i don't
i don't think there's a flick of a
switch
i think you evolve and you learn and you
continue to try and process
what you've been through and you know
there is a topic du jour isn't there
whether it's
personal branding over a few years ago
was meetups before that it was linkedin
before that it was something else right
and i think it's just making sure that
you're adding to what you're doing to
make sure you are using
i suppose relatively bleeding edge
recruitment techniques
so that you're not just dragged along
with it so that you have to do it
because everyone else is doing it
yeah and i think i think that the whole
branding i
i was always a bit cynical because i'd
seen so much
so during my time recruitment that said
there was the
what post dot com bubble bursting in
2001 and then 911 so
the world was difficult till 2004. and
then there's a financial thing 2007 2008
2010 11.
and then there's the oil and gas um
thing it absolutely killed us in 2014
2015 when
the oil cr oil price fell off a cliff so
you look at these things and i i used to
say well what's the point setting the
long-term vision because
there's always been something outside of
our control that dictates that we can't
do that
i was so wronged right because because i
think
if you if you say right this is where we
want to want to get to in three years
but and this is how we're gonna do year
one year two and year three if something
changes in year one
that's cool we just realign it and we go
again but if we're not talking about
our values and our vision and our
purpose then it means
[ __ ] up i mean you know we we we've had
a mission statement and values on our
wall
for years if you don't talk about that
if you don't get the pillars underneath
you to buy into that and talk about it
with their teams
and they talk about it with their teams
it's it
it's just a facade right yeah exactly
and and this is what i keep finding with
business owners
like yourself so just for context then
yeah so i'm assuming yeah just after the
the oil and gas
plummet what where was you as a business
like headcount wise
turnover wise just to give some context
as to the sort of growth and things
so um we've got turnover up to up above
10 million
um i think possibly one year we got into
mid teens
um at one stage we had as a building on
as many staff as we had now and
we'd opened up in singapore the plan was
that you know oscar will be open 24 7.
you know
uk us singapore over there and we'd also
won a bit of a mini rpo over in houston
when we first went over to the states
which it became a bit of a chain around
our neck actually because we made the
mistakes again but um
the next part of this big project was
going to be in the shipyards either of
south korea or singapore
we were told by the the business that
ran it that
any chance of getting the next stage of
it the fabrication part you've got to be
over there
and so that drove that a little bit but
we opened up singapore
and then within a year the world comes
crashing down in oil and gas we were too
spread to be able to at that point
bolster it with tech
so we shut it down and it it cost us
well over a million quid
you know and that's why i say our
our growth hasn't been linear it's been
up and down and
and as i said that you know one point
there our
65 of our nf
yeah absolutely yeah and that came
crashing down in in 2014-2015
and myself and then guy called matt
holmes who was a director who
when i came into oscar he was a a
consultant he was one of the good people
we built around
uh he went all the way through actually
to the same level as me not even the
director under me
and he his expertise was that part of it
me and him looked at the
the previous oil price crashes and every
single other wall in history
had bounced back to become greater
within a period of time
so sort of the shareholders and there's
pressures that get rid of oil and gas
it's gone instead we'll be like no no no
look at this
history data tells you yeah come back
um we maintained a presence in the uk
for
maybe six to nine months after it we had
we had a couple of corporate accounts
see
in the tech world we we have a real real
um
spread and and risk of this portfolio of
clients
um whereas an oil and gas is a couple of
real big corporate
businesses uh you know global players
and you've got these big accounts and
you think
if we stick in with this here we will
absolutely clean up afterwards
um but of course what happened was from
a contractor perspective there were a
lot of these huge big behemoth
recruitment agencies who are going
around
um mopping up all of the existing
contractors for like four percent markup
and stuff that
economies are scale-wise we can't
compete with we're a small business
and for the perm stuff that we were
quite good at which was sort of
bordering on search for a lot of these
high-level
oil and gas guys and we thought we still
we still sat in a really good place so
we maintained our
we maintained our our um
our uk function we were doing quite a
bit of stuff in the middle east
we essentially got screwed over by a
player over there
which we continue to do business with
but they never paid us but
you try getting money out of certain
places then you've got no chance
you're not hiding from nothing so look
we made super amount of mistakes again
it was driven probably by data driven
decisions and looking at history
and looking at putting our presence in
the market but um
we were wrong um and again set us back a
load
so we we transferred our oil and gas
practice over to the states completely
they transferred it there we just
stopped doing it in the uk and the
the guys who were doing the gas i had
the left of their own volition or
transferred into the tech team
and the uk became tech tech only
should we have done it sooner and
reacted more quickly with hindsight
which is always 20 20 vision
absolutely um but at the time
as i said it it wasn't decisions that
were made
on a whim or or without um
quality information behind them but we
still got it wrong so
singapore shut down um houston we
we had to we had to tag tech in onto the
back of that
which has since been been very
successful um
but again it was another fight it was
and at one point it was a bit of a fight
to survive and
we've sort of gone from our best best
ever place to a fight to survive to
really now building something where
i think it is very sustainable we've
learned a lot from those mistakes
and we're in our best iteration ever
what what do you think of
what what makes you feel more confident
and sustainable
um i think that
we we're now better spread um
although we still have the energy
practice um
out of that organically sprouted a
construction brand
we just this week
released a digital brand which again is
um
again it's just half a step away from
tech right and we all we already have
a footprint in that market um i think
we're nicely spread because we're across
across different economies
and we're across different industries um
and you know take take the coronavirus
thing which is obviously again it's the
topic on everybody's lips at the moment
and there appear to be different phases
of that
as a business we've fared pretty well um
we
we've gained it in head count of staff
slightly and we've been able to attract
some really really cool people that
possibly you know not to do ourselves
any disrespect but we might not have the
opportunity to speak to these guys in
other circumstances
and we've fared well and the u.s have
had consistent sales figures throughout
this period and haven't dropped
if you take the rolling average the uk
we had a bit of a plummet in april but
we gained 40
into may and 89 this june um in june of
this year we
we placed as many people as we did in
january when the market was brilliant
so far we're into the last week now of
july
this will be again just in terms of
sales in the uk and europe
this will be enough top it'll finish
somewhere between top
two to top four of months ever and i
think that's
because we we have better relationships
with clients
and we've learned as people that run the
business more
the culture is better so people won't
panic and leave or think about
uh their future necessarily um
and i think we have a better
understanding now
of how to deal with circumstances are
beyond your control
um from a psychological and a practical
perspective um
and i think to be honest with you
for me i know that this is going to
sound really wishy-washy and flaky
but our mindset now is that we will
carry on and be a success
despite what's happening and
irrespective of it rather than just
hoping we come through it
and i think that's one of the
differences that we have
to maybe some of the businesses um
from people i've interviewed recently
where
you know they're kind of they're kind of
saying well we'll just get through this
we're
we're talking about how we will come
through this best and how we will use it
to
to grow the business and and continue
to strengthen our position in the
markets right yeah so ultimately it's
the the diversification learnings from
that
and everything that you're talking about
there that that that's really
interesting so
what i wanted to dig in with you uh andy
one of the most common questions that i
always get
from personas from recruiters around
growing their business and i'm sure
the time is it's always like i get to
this sort of
certain milestone of headcount it might
be 15 20 heads and i always
keep coming back down going back up or
whatever so
i guess you've spoken a lot about
training you you've mentioned a bit
about culture which i'm going to dig
into after this
but what what do you think what how have
you
got better at hiring how have you got
better at understanding your hiring
triggers
and because i think that's something
that holds a lot of people back and i
think the the second part to that andy
is
what i see online is you've got a lot of
people that have stayed at oscar for a
while
so we always you always hear people
talking i need new hires new people that
can build this that are there but
what you clearly you've also been
impacted the retention but
what's been your learnings and how have
you got better at hiring
um i don't think we've got better at
hiring uh
when we're talking about those entry
level people and
i don't think we we've suddenly accessed
a different
level of graduate if that makes sense um
i think we've
become better if they if you're bringing
them into a better environment
then they will do better than they might
like to stay
if for me i think it's building pillars
and it's building role models and it's
having enough of those
i've always i always say to people in my
business who want to get up a level
i think it's super important to have
ideally three but if not two very strong
people underneath you
that you want to step into your shoes
and i think
um i actually think one of the real
really
important things that we've done is
generated a lot of female role models
from the business
um what makes a role model in the
recruitment business
what makes a good role model in your
opinion and
well there's a couple of ways of
answering that
i think because the the question could
be interpreted in a couple of different
ways
so if so what makes a role model and
this is important
i suppose to give context to it um
makes a role model as in what people
think a role model is is very very as
much is just important as to what makes
a good role model right
so if you if you're in
a business where so again one of the big
things we say about the change from a
few years ago looking back we have some
really strong
strong retreat with strong builders
people who've gone to other businesses
who
are good at the job and trained well and
i think we
like me being honest sometimes maybe had
a bit of fear of losing those people and
allowed them to maybe
set the tone and set the culture a
little bit more than we did
as a business holistically and i think
sometimes that puts blockers on other
people
who are afraid to then find their voice
and i think that
one of the best things that we ever did
was say
we we call it we call it being on the
oscar bus
right and we a few years ago we sacked a
couple of people who were really good
billers
and it was the best thing we ever did um
and it wasn't about
those people personally they're good
people we get on now but
why was it the best thing you did
because
it was it was drawing a line in the sand
that we are about a lot more than that
and it's it's about it's about the
contribution you make
to the whole which isn't just financial
um
and the the greatest greatest
recruitment builders can absolutely be
your biggest blockers on growth
and i went through a lot of time going
but if we lose then we could lose
half a million pound revenue this year
or whatever but somebody inevitably owes
if you've got that right the rest of it
right somebody will step up
and somebody will step up who maybe
isn't um
a a um maybe somebody who
who then maybe puts forward the wrong
message um
and we've got this big thing about being
on the bus and i think once you have the
this is the big thing and i i i take
this from this phrase from
other senior people in the industry that
i learn a lot from if you make it
cool to be good and that's that goes out
with that whole role model thing is if
the role models you want because let's
have it right
quite often we're grown up at school you
know you look up to the cool kids or the
naughty kids right yeah yeah
the people the role models the kids who
get straight a's not necessarily right
and i think that even when you go into
your 20s the same thing sort of applies
and i think if you can try and change
that culture and make it cool to be good
that is the biggest thing and that was
one of the biggest changes that we had
and you could you create that culture by
ensuring that the people are success
are good good people good for the
business we all talked about where the
company had been on the oscar bus
and inevitably those people get the the
best success longer term
um but i would much rather have a
greater number of
good billers than two or three super
billers so i can say hey my top builder
is 1.8 million this year
i'd rather stay i've got 10 people that
do half a mill each right
yeah um i think people buy into
that more people respect it more um and
listen
we're not we're not stick in the mud or
anything like that we have a lot of fun
uh within our business crikey you know
it's a lively culture
but i think that there is there is a
line and the the
there's when you when you when you
create that and you realize that's where
you want to go to naturally it builds an
equality within the business
and that you you'll find that role
models will come forward
that have a different voice to what to
what you've had previously
when you have that happen you've
naturally
received more ideas and you evolved yeah
i was going to say i feel like
if i'm an employee of yours and sort of
there's a sort of undertone of like
there's this top builder that they they
do feel they're a bit toxic or they
aren't quite aligned with the rest of
the culture what andy's trying to
communicate change and i can see that
and then andy the leader takes the
decision to go you know what
yeah we need to get rid of these people
when as an employee if i then see that
of course that's going to encourage
that's going to encourage more
more of the right people right and yeah
those people free which is really
interesting
i mean those people that kind of moved
on from the business
they're not inherently bad people right
but they're not there's a frustration of
theirs
or something's happening in their
personal life or something's uh
meaning that they are then causing
disaffection in the business
um quite often subconsciously um
sometimes it's so it's very very over
and then you deal with that
differently of course but for us it's
made such a huge difference
um you know and some of the role models
we've got in the business at the moment
are just incredible people
and why why you mentioned why why do you
why did you go to
female role models why has that been
important and why has that had an impact
what do you think and because
and it was it's not been done by design
but
since we've had um a large amount of
female
senior managers ads
um it's definitely balanced to culture
because
the conversation driven by those people
the voice isn't always and listen i love
talking about football well maybe not
the moment
right but but you know it's not just
about football or the pub or whatever
it's completely balanced
and there's always somebody to look up
to who's probably a little bit like them
you know and my the directors that we
have in place that run the recruitment
population
kevin the us and matt in the u in the uk
really really different types of people
and that's really useful as well
to get those ideas from i mean it's it's
difficult sometimes when you're hiring
because they have very different
opinions
um but i think having that variety of
thought
um absolutely brings new ideas to the
table because
if you become quite often i believe
um the sum of your surroundings right
you were kind of indoctrinated by it or
whatever you know
part of that culture and i think if
everybody you bring through is the same
is going to be a carbon copy of you
and it kind of goes against what i said
earlier on in the interview about sort
of copying what people do
from the same success i think that's a
framework but i think within that you
need different thoughts you need
different
views on the world and again a
recruiting leader i look up to an awful
lot said this a couple years ago and
it's really simple but blew my mind if
you if you change the way you look at
things the things you look at change
um and quite often you know what you've
you've been writing a
you know an rfi or something you've
looked over it with the same eyes and
again and again and again
you can't see the obvious mistakes right
because it's the same eyes
so as a business if we bring different
eyes into it
and for me a lot of that actually has
been about me expanding
my mind outside of the organization
instead of being head down
and networking with other recruitment
leaders you get different viewpoints now
worst case scenario and this is absolute
worst case scenario
and you get affirmation that you're on
the right path and you're probably doing
the right thing
yeah best case scenario you learn there
is
something else that you can add to what
you're doing or change or evolve
so it's win-win yeah and that's that's
for me that's an external thing and an
internal thing too
that's really interesting so yeah so
again if
giving people in your business an
opportunity to look up and see a real
diverse
mix of people who are role models that's
gonna
yeah that's so interesting um a lot of
it's about letting go it's giving people
a voice because
let's have it right in in any industry
you can put somebody in a role and call
them a manager or a leader
if you're not allowing them to manage
your lead they're not they're just
they're your voice in this little echo
change yeah yeah yeah um and i think
the traditional method and something
that's worked really well for us in the
last few years actually
is changing our thinking on things is
traditional recruitment thing
it's it's meritocracy is a really really
cool thing but there's a dark side
tricks if you're not doing well you
don't enjoy the fact that
somebody who's been with you less time
does better than you right so
there's always two sides to that coin
but with meritocracy
you earn it you get it you earn it you
get it right but there are sometimes
some people that have got super
potential in an area
but something's just holding them back
and if you go well just wait until you
do this and then
we'll give you this responsibility
they're never going to get that
but they could be really good if you
give them responsibility anyway and one
of the things that again that we've
probably changed in the last few years
was letting go me again it's part of me
getting rid of that perfectionist side a
little bit and going do you know what
you're not quite there yet
you're probably not ready for this go
for it because
the mistakes you'll you'll make now will
absolutely
be overcome by the good and the extra
stuff that you'll bring to it post when
you get to to that point you've gotten
to anyway
um and for us as as a business there's
a couple of people where i've known
they've wanted something and you should
be just
not doing the sales figures i'm not
doing something else that's quite
getting there and we've and we've gone
do you know what
let's do it let's take a point i i i'm
trusting in you
i think you'll pay me back whereas the
normal equation is
is yeah you you earn it we give you and
then we get there and now
sometimes that doesn't work and the
problem with that kind of stuff is it
becomes very subjective and it can cause
issues because
people say what about me as well right
um but i think if you do it based on the
right behaviors
i think it goes down really well and
you'll it's risks you'll take and
it won't all pay off but you'll win more
you'll lose and
that way i think you can expedite growth
so what i want to talk to you about andy
because what i see from you online and
the sort of um
i've had a couple of interactions with
different recruiters from your business
and
i think it's sort of i saw on your
linkedin profile you put
i work for my people yeah don't normally
hear that right
yeah but so i guess it's what you're
talking about here is like what's been
your
sort of business leader journey like it
seems like you've been on a bit of a
journey there you've become more
vulnerable you
you've had to let go as you're just
talking about but yeah
but what have you recognized in in
hindsight or i know this is an ongoing
process right but
what have you had to get better at or
what what sort of key things have
you gone through or changed as a leader
that you think has had an impact on
the business i think lots i mean
it's an ongoing it's an ongoing like you
say it's evolving you you
you it's a journey rather than a
destination you know all those cheesy
sort of metaphors
i think um there's been a number that
may be concentrated in your mind because
that's the stage you're at at that point
right so
i mean i i did a similar sort of podcast
a couple of years ago i would probably
give a different answer to the one i do
now
because i'm in a different place right
and i think
for me you get as you evolve i i've
always
really genuinely genuinely genuinely
well meant well
for anybody who works with me be it from
when i had my first trainee ross who
who's a director of that business now
through to the people who
who i work with now who some of them are
thousands of miles away and only see me
three or four times a year
and genuinely i will never ask anybody
to run through a brick wall that i
wouldn't run through first
but i think that sometimes
in maybe in the early days that wasn't
clear
and you're pushing people and they don't
get they don't necessarily get
get that you will do that for them when
you're not billing it's very difficult
to show them because you have to do
other things
and i think for me style of style of
engagement and style of communication
you know um you know we've all read the
book but
you know my chimp still comes out quite
regularly you know and i have to put him
back in his box
and you know being a relatively emotive
person but i think
i think it's it's trying to it's trying
to learn from those experiences
when there's a decision to be made and
not just jumping to what make what makes
you feel a certain way
is crucially important and i think that
again a very good
good friend of mine a sales trainer
called trevor pinder says don't ever
stray too far from your genius
i think i went through i went through a
couple of years where i think i was a
relatively ineffective leader
and i didn't feel like it at the time
because i've done a lot to try and look
after people and i felt like i've
maybe not had the same loyalty in return
you know people forget the 99 things you
do for him that's great and always
remember the one where you made them
feel crap right we all know that
and and and that pissed me off because i
did a lot of stuff to sort of got on my
way to help people
but it's it's the way of things and i
think i was afraid for a couple years to
be honest with a few years ago of giving
too much of myself
wow um because i thought if i do that
i'll end up in the same position again
and i i i i've slowly but surely just
learned that i'm not really enjoying
this i'm not being me
what i do need to do is i need to learn
i was always trying to do the right
thing and i think it's
it's learning to make sure that that
everybody understands that and
that's down to you it's not their fault
it's not you it's done for you to to
communicate with them properly
and actually you should again that whole
strain away from your genius
i think you've got to be really again
really overused where you've got to be
authentic
and i think that once i return to being
authentic again again it's probably
coincided with four years ago
was really finding ourselves as a
business again
um and i mean you know from a technical
perspective
in terms of things you learn
leadership-wise while you know
there's ongoing stuff you could you can
never learn too much
i think that's really interesting andy
because i think that's something as a
leader or as a business owner you've
got to be because i feel like what
you're saying there is that you've had
to get you had to get really comfortable
with
giving without the expectation of
getting something
in return or like or it or being in a
place of giving to
sort of in the back of your mind go i
hope that
they do actually take this and they
preach my loyalty because
if you don't because clearly when you
are doing that and you're thinking well
if i give and then i'd
and then they don't give back or
whatever it can affect that can't it
it can't yeah yeah i mean yeah i mean
you think about all the relationships in
your life that you know
it should be quid pro quo bot craft and
it's not you know
that i think there's a french ever
saying in the relationship there's a
kisser and the kiss
you know and somebody always has
ultimately has that um
that that power and but i think for me
if you it it's about continuing to try
and show people that you are
you're doing this for them as much as
you and create in that that environment
there's a couple of leaders underneath
me have been technically fabulous and
and and they kind of i can see in them
what i used to be like as well
and it's really really um it's not easy
for me to work with them but i can work
with them on it because i've been
through that journey myself
help them with those things it's
something i'm very passionate about and
listen
i'll still make mistakes as a leader now
but i think quite often i'm trying to
with our business it's it's it's really
really
it's not autocratic anymore anymore
nowhere near and i think it's allowing
those people to feel like
that they have an impact on the business
means that they will have an impact
perhaps on the business
which means i suppose that then on a
personal level
my my my my emotions
of what actual iphones what we've got
right yeah
and um i'm really proud of what we've
done and what we continue today
so as we come to the end here and i just
wanted to just have a bit of a focus on
we've spoken a lot about growth and
these things but obviously
to create sustainable growth you've had
to keep hold of
some of your best people which typically
can be really difficult
and something that you're worried about
talking about there giving a lot and
whatever so like what do you think have
been i know we've spoken about culture
and these things it's no doubt all
contribute to it but
what do you think have been some of the
things that you've done as a business
that has really impacted the retention
of your staff do you think um
i think we've
we've won quite a lot of awards in the
last couple of years for sort of best
recruitment coming to work for we were
number one on the sunday times and the
best companies as a recruitment business
and
a lot of it a lot of people sort of take
to that i was talking to a friend of
mine as a recruitment leader
last week and he he's very cynical about
all that kind of stuff
my response is that again that's
something you get
as as um as a spin-off from what you
what you're doing to help you
with that retention all the rest of it
if you do those things just for the sake
of having a gun on your wall
people see through that pretty quickly
and i think that
again it's probably about four years ago
um
i think just decided to to go balls out
and go
let's do what we think is right rather
than what the rest of the
the the world is doing now it doesn't
mean that individually we're doing
anything that's absolutely unique
but i think it's doing what feels right
so i mean take the there's this whole
thing about um
mental health is super important right
and i'm a big big bad advocate
of working with mental health as much as
physical health uh
and the two are intertwined of course as
well but like you know mental health
world day or whatever people put loads
of [ __ ] on linkedin then forget about it
you know stuff like that that we talk
about and
and deal with and support every single
day and every single week of the year
that's really really important um and i
think
for me a lot of it what we've created is
an environment where it's it's there
it's real it's true
it's not just for the cameras so to
speak yeah um you know we've got we
employ a psychologist
hannah who's an amazing lady and who
um comes in and does group sessions on
on mindfulness and resilience but also
um we pay for individual sessions and
you know it's it's
it's 100 quid a pop right and there are
numerous people that we pay for
a weekly basis for people that are
struggling with a variety of different
things
now i bet we're not the only bit
recruitment business out there that does
that but our staff knows we mean it
you know we and it's the intention that
matters isn't it
yeah yeah you know and you know we've
we've got
we've got a mental health app that we
give to everybody but there's also that
the whole thing you know we started
doing longer lunches for the gym and
and for all that kind of stuff and
people go do i have to work so half an
hour later tonight
because i've gone i was like no no no
just just take it use it for me
it's not completely altruistic i think
you'll come back in the afternoon bust
up anyway
and do a better job if you have to set
your desk for an extra 30 minutes just
because you've gone for
lunch for for a longer period of time
it's [ __ ]
you may have got yourself to work yeah
yeah and i think i think it's just
we are run by recruiters who very
recently or somewhat recently in my
in my experience i'm older i've been in
the position of the people who work for
us right
and i think it's it's it's remembering
what how you felt
what you thought you know when you're a
kid and and you say to your mum that
when i'm a parent i'm not going to be
like you i hate your mum and dad
and then you become a parent you go oh
my god i'm my dad right
because what they were doing was the
right thing to do the key is to try
it is it's that communication so they
know you're doing it for the right
reasons
and that that comes from mental health
from physical health and rewarding
people from
it's little things that we that we do
you know our
um all of our social stuff we have a
social committee i give them a budget
they do it so it's not
what andy and the doctor want to do yeah
our charity committee just decided for
and run by the individuals so that you
know this
this isn't a wishy-washy community you
know cooperative community or anything
but it's having people know that their
decisions and how they feel
will have a direct effect on their
environment yeah and that's really
really important
and they've been empowered to do that
it's not handy yeah
yeah and it it is listening to changes
and then you know when i first started
in recruitment
it was all about the money right it's
big fat knots in your tie and that kind
of stuff
now people cherish more than anything
else time
time that you know it's been a bit it's
the most important commodity we have
so you know give you an example every
single month we run an incentive
for teams so they all get it or none of
them get it the earlier finishes the
the following month so we're we're
clocking off at one o'clock today as
we're doing every friday this month
because
the teams hit all the targets in june
because some of them and in fact most of
them would probably prefer
that over at x amount of 100 pounds
bonus we used to get anywhere in the
commission and it's listening and
learning to what is becoming more
important to them because
generation by generation although a lot
of them will feel the way you felt when
you were doing the job
what means to them what matters to them
is different you know um
we we've we've addressed the the
diversity and equality thing
an awful lot um recently and had a good
look at ourselves as far as that's
concerned as well
and because it's a it's an important
topic to the people that work for us
and we we kind of thought we were doing
well enough by
having a dni policy and saying we don't
employ [ __ ] and we don't let a
bullying happen but as the ceo of the
business i i i
i looked at myself and when was the last
time andy you actually looked at your
equality policy properly
and it was probably because of filling
out tender right so that's not good
enough
yeah so you know you you're learning and
that's because
the recent events that have happened in
the world are affecting the guys that
work for us some of them directly
actually and we we've got a
we've got an actual direct tangible two
or two direct tangible responses that
we're doing
in response to that because i understand
i mean this
we are if you cut one of us we all bleed
and we're a team
you know that's the way we work and it's
important that not look listen not
everybody will agree with every decision
we make as a business right
because that's never going to happen but
you've got to listen and you've got to
learn and you've got to be open-minded
you've got you've got to realize
sometimes that
what was always right isn't so right now
yeah no i love that andy um look but
before before we finish i just wanted to
focus on one part what you just said
it's it's something that
i've always encouraged and spoken about
and been passionate about with this
podcast with with the mental health
piece
um because i think it's it's what we're
saying i'm just have you do you know
ronda
ambrosio no but um i
saw a link to the podcast you did with
her this morning actually yeah so
so and so why i wanted to just hone in
on that and is because
i think one of the most difficult things
that i hear from leaders
when it comes to mental health is like
how they start cultivating
their culture to talk about it or impose
things like that you the things that
you've done
like how how did you start that because
obviously i'm sure you didn't have those
things in place before
clearly you listened clearly you
obviously communicated with people this
is something that's important
clearly the intention's got to be right
but how did you start implementing this
in your business because i think that
that worries a lot of people they don't
know where to start they don't want to
sort of get people to feel
awkward or difficult i don't know how
did you go about
sort of implementing this so i think
people can get a lot of value from that
yeah honestly i don't know i don't don't
really i don't i don't i don't remember
us deciding one day
this is a problem we need we need to
challenge it but
i think the the thing with mental health
is that there's a big umbrella term
and we all have we all have mental
health yeah um
in the same ways we all have physical
health and it's it's not consistent
you know um and i think because
everybody
everybody's dealing with their own stuff
in their life all the time
and i think again i i don't remember
something happening i was going right
we've got to deal with this but
i i i i it's evolved with the and
what i did what i learned is that a lot
of the time it's the little things
so i've got i've got a couple of guys
who work in our head office so i see
them every day
um who who have um
challenges with the certain aspects of
mental health and
this is just a tiny little thing but
it's an example of what works so
if they're having one of those days as
they call it
and they're struggling with it we have a
an agreement they just kind of give me a
like a bit of a wink or you know like a
tip of the hat it's one of those days
because the anxiety for them
is actually telling you that they're not
feeling all right so you go through a
process
to learn what helps them feel less
anxious in the first place so it's just
a bit of a
you know i've got somebody where they
they just said they just tell me what's
up and and just say
it's one of those days i'll be working
from home today and we've generated that
culture where
that that's cool that's what happens
because that's the way that makes them
feel less anxious about these things
yeah
so just just quickly on that andy
because i think this is the part that's
quite challenging
how did you encourage these because i
think one of the things that's hard is
getting
their your people to talk about this so
how did you i guess this comes from you
being vulnerable and and you
sort of sort of being the leader that
you are but how did you get these people
to open up to the point where they
where you've decided that actually yeah
this is what works for me this will
really help but they've got to talk to
you about it first that's that can be
difficult
for leaders to get people to open up
about
[Music]
it's a it question um i think
i think i think a lot of it is building
an environment so that
the the people that can help those that
are vulnerable
and we're all vulnerable right but
everybody's got that person to go to
call him a manager a stakeholder
director or
your pal whatever i think it's creating
an environment first of all where
there's trust
and where they know that that trust
won't be compromised and again that
sounds like a really wishy-washy answer
but i think that's the most important
thing but you don't do that purely for
the purpose of mental health you do that
for the well-being of people generally
and the good of the company
i think once you create that kind of
environment i think people find it easy
to entrust anyway i mean
it's interesting people still come to me
we've got hr department and people got
their own managers and some people do
still come to me
you know something you just have
connections with some people or you
don't yeah and
and some people come to me and talk
about it and i'll say look you're not
the only person to feel
fit to feel like this i can't name names
because that's also not fair
that i think that's the that's the
really the really interesting paradox
with the talking about stuff is
you can't talk about other people
because it's not fair on them but you
have to know that it's okay to be able
to talk
yeah i think inherently in the business
now
people know that they might not know who
is struggling today or generally or what
have you but they know they just kind of
know it's okay because
they can trust they'll trust that their
person above them will do that
it's knowing somebody will do the right
thing with the information that's the
right thing by you
and the business not just the right
thing by the business and that's the
important thing
our hr manager is incredible at it and
he's he's
so empathetic but he's also balanced as
well you know
and and i think i think i
i think it's important that the message
is consistent as i said it's not just on
mental health we put a load of jargon on
linkedin and pretty pictures
and then never mean it i think it's
having it's having sessions with
external help consistently you know
we've had a number of different
sort of experts or so you know subject
matter people coming to talk to us about
stuff because
quite often what one person says will
will resonate with a number of people
what somebody else delivers differently
to resonate with others and i think it's
making sure that you consistently push
that and
when you do that and you spend your own
money on it as a business and you spend
time on it and it's not time out of
their date they're doing it in core
hours they're doing in the middle of the
day
they know that you mean it then yeah the
attention again isn't it
yeah and it's consistency of approach uh
and i think it
it's it's probably we still make
mistakes
but i think it's them probably seeing in
what we do that we are mindful
in the decisions that we make um
and it should just quickly ended like
how open have you because because i've
spoken to a lot of people about this and
so when we talk about moving the needle
and making change typically the answer
is it's got to start from the top
so clearly you've got a hr person that
has the the capability of being
empathetic being in other people
choosing these things but
i think you as a business leader how
open have you
how open have you been with your staff i
don't know brown because i think this is
the part of the challenge as well as
like okay well
everyone's telling me it needs to start
from the top does that mean that i have
to stand in front of everyone and tell
me
all my struggles like where do i go
where do i draw the line like how open
have you been as a
leader with your stuff around yourself
your journey
i think if you decide the way forward to
start this is me
standing up and addressing everybody and
saying you know i've struggled to get
out of bed this morning and blah blah
for the sake of starting that process i
don't think that's authentic and i don't
i think people see through it
i think if you create the culture where
you can go and sit down as the ceo of
the business you can go sit down with
the trainee
or the business administrator as well as
the fd or a recruiter or whatever
and you can have the same sort of
conversations and you can be open about
your life to a point wherever you're
comfortable with
you know um i think again that creates
that environment um
i think it's important that they see you
know they'll see us as business leaders
backing it as i said before with our
with our money which most people are
cynical about for recruitment businesses
you know all that they're keeping all
the money themselves and sitting in
these ivory towers or whatever
so i think my wife wished was true but
it's not real
um but you know um i don't know i don't
for me i think if that feels right then
yeah do it
if it doesn't and it's not you i don't
think that's the right way to start it
because
the whole point of this is is being
allowed to be yourself and to feel a
certain way
so being forced to do something that you
think is right for everybody else that
isn't right for you it's probably the
wrong starting point
um so i think personally i i'm no expert
buddy at all but
for me i think it's it's about that that
authenticity again
i mean for me i don't i'm i'm happy to
tell people about certain parts of my
life
absolutely and i i wouldn't want to tell
everybody every single worry because
i also have a duty of care to not pass
every single worry on to everybody else
otherwise they'll be on eggshells around
me
and i think because i'm my
responsibility as a business leader is
different to others well that doesn't
mean that i can't tell people when i'm
upset or when i'm
i mean i'm i'm pretty easy to read
anyway
in fact i think my my challenges and my
weaknesses have probably been that i've
been too open
and and be too easy to read and said is
that you know putting the chimp back in
thing about
about and maintaining a level head you
know it's it's being that swan isn't it
um
but and i think that there is a very
very again and no mental health expert
but again having listened to a lot of
the experts on this subject
i think it is a very fine balance and
it's showing vulnerability but it's also
not panicking people as well
um and it's showing them support but
it's also not
you know again being honest it's it's
it's not
not allowing them to to to make such a
big deal of something that
you can make it worse by overreacting it
with them as well
and again it's finding that balance it's
supporting people and giving them what
they need
but it's not allowing them to maybe be
self-destructive at the same time
because i've also sometimes been too
lenient and then actually what you did
allows somebody so much
breath that they caught on to themselves
in that way and
and again that's a learning curve and
it's knowing when to stand up and it's
i don't i don't know it's an interesting
subject which is why you know you'll
you'll be able to do full talks with
people about this who have got a lot
more to say
about themselves you know um
so look andy you've been in the the
industry for for a while this is
obviously a very unique
circumstance that we find ourselves in
but how how do you see this sort of
landlay
in the next six or 12 months in the
recruitment industry what do you think
is gonna
stay stick around what do you what sort
of do you think are going to be maybe
some of the biggest changes that you'll
keep an eye on not interested to see how
it plans out
what's going through sort of your head
and if you're looking at the next six to
12 months
yeah i think i mean i think one of the
the big things everybody's talking about
the christ there's a million polls about
it on linkedin is
is is what sort of the working
environment logistics is going to look
like
yeah and that's for us international
recruitment businesses
and it's also a challenge for our
clients as well
and i i think that is going to be the
the topic for a while along with
obviously how
how the economy recovers um and i think
that's really really interesting
um and i think like you know we've
experimented recently we've taken on
two remote consultants that we've never
done before um two lads are cracking
fellas who are up in philadelphia
you know we haven't got an office up in
philly um but we we've sort of decided
that
in this sort of new world we're gonna
trial stuff and we're gonna see what
works for us and
for me i think i think the working
remotely working from home thing is
absolutely here to stay
some people were further along the curve
than we are now some people were a long
way behind it
and i think you know i talked to my
leadership internally about this and
i don't have the exact long-term answer
just yet because i don't think we are in
what the consistent new future is going
to be yet
yeah but i think what's really important
to me is that we try
we try stuff now we've got three
different working patterns now which is
completely elective
people choose exactly what it is they
want to do work from here and work from
the office or do
do a 3-2 mix um a 3-2 mixer is at three
days
off is two days home yeah yeah most
most of us including me are doing 3-2
mix which i never thought would do
because i was like get me away from the
kids and get me to work but i'm
i now cherish that 20 minutes at lunch
where i can see the kids or
you know i finish and i don't have the
hour commute home and stuff like that
but
i wouldn't want to be here all the time
but again it's not assuming that
everybody wants the same thing as me
yeah yeah and that's really important
but i think for me i think
the reason why we're trying lots of
different tracks with this at the moment
um you know a lot of my recruitment
mates think i'm daft i get everybody
back in you know it's all about the
environment the culture and the office
which it is that's big big part you talk
to any of my guys why are you still the
business the people the people yeah
the environment and but i think
for me it's going to happen right and i
would rather we find our
our little voice in this world and our
way of doing it at the suit source
before you're dragged along by the
coattails because well if you don't have
any working from home everyone's going
to leave you and work from joe blogs up
the road who are doing it this way
i'd rather us find out what works for us
by our own volitions
and because again it's like it's like
the mental health thing it's like the
blm things
oh we've got to say something because
we've got to be seen to do you know what
i mean
i don't want us to have i have freedom
for our guys to work in different places
and flexibility
because we feel like we have to give it
there yeah that's [ __ ] that's a
great way to
look at it i think there's diminishing
returns on that i think you've got to do
it and
for me i'd rather find out earlier make
the mistakes now and find out so we're
into our pattern
and then also i think you you're
probably in a better place to be able to
help your clients need candidates with
it because they'll face the same
struggles as well
because you're going through the same
journey um but i think that's going to
be a very very important topic
and i think for us for the industries
we're recruiting for if we're smart
as i think we have been so far and work
hard i think
there's no reason why we can't come
through this pretty well um but
the the fear at the moment is is there a
bit of a dead cat bounce with regards to
hiring you know was there
two or three months worth of pent-up
hiring and spending that's
being done all of a sudden in june and
july and and then it slows down when the
further scheme ends and things like that
so
that there are there are a million
different um variables at the moment
that
i think are going to affect us going
forwards a second spike
you know i i'm sure everybody with the
salt is now making sure that they are
a lot sort of um more tightly put
together in case that happens or for
when it happens
and again we don't know what what
sanctions will be imposed on the way we
work at that point in time anyway
so i think it's just making sure that
you are aware of that and and in any
which way
it goes you have a plan or probably five
plans
right yeah no i love that i think it's a
great way to view
actually yeah let's use this time to
experiment it uses time to listen to our
people what was what doesn't i think
that's great
um final question if andy could uh
communicate to recruiters
recruitment business owners the the
recruitment people
they'd listen to your advice they'd
implement it what what would
andy say to the people ah
i've tried to spend an hour talking
about that i don't
you know what one piece of advice i i
always struggle with this because
again as i said before i think it
depends what's in your mind at that
moment in time you can ask me tomorrow
and say something completely different
i think um one of the the biggest things
that
has changed me i think in the last few
years
is being open to outside influence and
uh being aware that you know your
competition out there out there
are not the bunch of [ __ ] you
thought they were you know um
and and people will share and there are
kindred spirits and
whether that's from official networking
groups of which i'm a member of a couple
uh or whether it's just reaching out to
people what i've seen in
in kobe times is recruiters come
together as a body
probably being honest because they've
been forced to because we're in the same
state even though we're in different
sized boats um but i think
for me i i i would like to see the
recruitment industry carry that on more
and support each other more um because
that way i think that
a lot of the the tainting on our
industry will slowly
uh become to disappear there's other
reasons as well
but i think that the biggest the biggest
reason for it is
is that competition i mean don't get me
wrong i still want oscar to be
every business out there right um but
i'll have a chat with people and
my door's open to anybody to talk about
that and
i help lots of people with businesses
when they come to me for god knows why
and
but i also i've there's really cool
people i can call on as well
and for me that is so super important
and you can do that as a
from a training recruiter up to a
business owner yeah andy i love that
it's been a pleasure okay thanks